Chantelle I want to be my own company of
organic products for the body but i have
no finances now or guidance as to how i
start who do I seek advice from I am 28
years old so starting the company we're
going to progress doesn't have finances
needs wisdom guidance 28 years old
Chantelle southern come this is an
interesting one because this is yeah you
could argue a pretty crowded market so I
think you need a differentiated what is
it you've got around organic products
whether it's skincare or whatever which
is very different i think to Evans point
you've got to really believe in your
product you've got to love your idea you
gotta love your product because that's
the first essence you got to have you
got then think secondly how do i
differentiate myself because you know
there's this candidly it's probably a
sea of mediocre fights out there but
it's a noisy market so what do you do
differently and then all the other
things evans talked about in terms of
kind of market testing market tested
with your friends market st with other
people find the market and then again
once you've done that then you can scale
up set up a website whatever in terms of
the distribution make it a point to use
great products like sage pay on your
website you can do all that sort of
stuff as well now what i would argue is
when you sell but no money don't
underestimate it because if you got good
products with all these things golden
rule of business is net expenses get
ahead of revenues so go and do a bit of
test driving with stuff even your
friends if it's a great product they'll
pay five bucks for it and with these
sort of products typically the
manufacturing costs it should be like
eighty ninety percent gross margin
business so if you got the sort of
pricing right you could do test drive
and you could get in enough money to go
to the next stage and you kind of want
to break it down and skinny it down in
these little increments well you don't
scale up or do stupid stuff but you just
do baby steps on a big idea that you you
go to a market but it is a crowded
market I think Evans got a lot of
experience in this space so what are
your thoughts of them to me either lack
of financing is similar to somebody seen
there too
or they're too young it's just another
limiting belief it's another excuse it's
it's like oh I don't come from the right
family or I didn't get the right
education or you know in my country you
can't do this and it's never about the
resources as an entrepreneur it's about
you're resourceful pneus and if you go
back and you look at any other guys who
have started the companies that you look
up to in the cosmetics business look at
the founder you know they started in
their kitchen miss teen ingredients
putting things in jars and selling them
like you may not look at uh you know the
body shop now and say you know a lot I
need to get that kind of distribution
and that's not possible I need to raise
millions of dollars to do it but the
body shop was started because I need
erotic her husband left her to go ride a
horse from Argentina to New York City
that was his dream and so took him a
year and a half to do that and so she
need to make money support herself with
her husband on this huge trip and so she
just started selling stuff that she made
in jars and that's the start right so
it's never about how much money you have
get started now with what you have and
start selling to your friends and to
Stevens Point find something that's
different because there are a ton of
products out there but it's don't don't
hold onto the excuse that I don't have
the money to do this because it's always
about how resourceful you are and the
most successful entrepreneurs likely
started with less than what you already
have right now you already have all the
resources you need to be successful Evan
message I think that it's a key key
aspect of the greater the innovation and
the more creative you get the less money
you have because you have to and and
actually even even though you know such
as a big company buys I say to be where
every day treat the company's money as
if it's your own sink like a start-up
you know what would you do what would
you stop what were you double down the
how how do we make a difference to
customers and I think the greatest
entrepreneurs I'd met you know whether
it's the Branson's all these guys it
just started with nothing they started
with you know he is a guy who started
with a loan from his arm you know a
couple of hundred bucks and that would
sit and then build a multi-million
Empire now I do
think is a good kind of culture and
philosophy to run your business kind of
Lena mean even when you scale up but
starting you've got a pic pic
something's big idea pursue your
passions get a product 8 even if you
kind of mix it in the kitchens get a fan
base and then think about you know the
other innovations what other mixes or
never think that you're locked into a
kind of cul-de-sac where you have to do
the same all the time early stage of
business you got to be innovating all
the time you might even change the
product every day based on feedback from
your customers and I think the other
thing that's really important there is
what it does is be open in your mind to
where it takes you because you'll never
know where you end up as a business and
and every business that starts with an
idea the end product that they build is
very often different from where they
started so be very open to that FIBA and
again through social media wow what a
great way to get social antenna on what
your customers love about your products
and what you need to change ya mean to
that point you look at a couple like
Wrigley's that's made his fortune in
gone they started off selling baking
soda and gum was just a bonus that for
every you know five packs of baking soda
you get a free pack of gum and the gum
just took off so started selling the gum
you look at BMW and their logo that
circle is a propeller because they still
go up making airplanes and then they got
out of the airplane business and one of
the cars and so it's it's super common
to the switch